Trump is leading in all the polls by a
lot including in Florida now this is
really tough number for Ron DeSantis
from Florida Atlantic University FAU
poll Trump is up 20 points on DeSantis
in Florida Trump said 50 percent
DeSantis 30 Vivek four percent Tim Scott
three percent Chris Christie the
Christmas not looking as great as it
once did two percent it's down there
with Asa Hutchinson Pence two percent
Haley one percent even when you just put
DeSantis and Trump against one another
head to head so you say okay well you
don't want the field to to water down
desantis's support what's it look like
when they're up against each other Head
to Head Trump's numbers go up actually
54 to 37 so it's his numbers go up
objectively 54 versus 50. but then he
still maintains a 17-point lead over to
Santa's